[Musique]
oh
je suis une solitaire qui n'est pas
toujours à l'aise dans ce monde
je vais même vous avouer comme ça dès la
première minute
pendant longtemps je n'aimais pas les
humains les animaux la nature oui
c'était mes ressources quand j'étais
enfant mais jamais pas les humains vers
l'âge de 4 ans que j'observais quand
j'étais avec les autres enfants
c'était dur au jet de l'humiliation la
compétition j'ai vite compris que
l'humain et est la seule espèce capable
de détruire tout en ayant conscience de
le faire et j'avais pas envie
d'appartenir à cette espèce j'ai grandi
dans une cité l'atmosphère était
violente visibles et non visibles et il
n'y avait pas vraiment d'adultes pour
réguler ça moi j'étais une enfant
précoce hypersensible j'ai pas du tout
réussi à m'adapter aux autres enfants
j'en parle pas souvent rarement même
mais pendant des années à l'école j'ai
été maltraité est tabassé par les autres
enfants
j'en ai gardé des stigmates
psychologiques à des douleurs physiques
que je soigne encore aujourd'hui j'étais
d'une timidité maladive mode de survie
transparente
vous savez comme ces poissons au fond de
l'eau qui prennent la couleur du sol
pour se camoufler
tout me faisait peur parlez à la
boulangère me faisait peur monte sur
scène pour assister des poèmes je vous
en parle même pas vivre ensemble ça
relevait du défi pour moi comment on
fait pour vivre en harmonie les uns avec
les autres
quand tous les jours on se fait harceler
quand tous les jours on se sent en
danger comment fait pour se relier avec
les autres cantons à la croyance dès
l'enfance que le jeu s'oppose aux nous
et que le monde est hostile donc vers
l'âge de 5 ans j'ai trouvé refuge dans
les salles de cinéma pour tenter de
comprendre l'homme et m'évader de mon
quotidien
quand on me demandait ce que je voulais
faire quand j'étais petit je répondais
réalisatrice parce que je voulais offrir
aux gens ce que le cinéma m'avait offert
alors pendant des années pendant plus de
vingt ans j'ai travaillé sur des
tournages de films
mais comme j'étais discrète et que je
manquais de confiance en moi eh ben je
me suis naturellement planqué derrière
les réalisateurs à les aider et les
soutenir à faire leur film
mais petit à petit je trouvais plus de
sens à ma vie
un jour je me suis réveillé et je me
suis dit il faut que j'arrête de vis ma
vie à moitié mais pour ça j'ai eu besoin
d'arrêter de suivre le chemin guider par
mes peurs quand je disais regarder en
face ses peurs
eh ben je me suis rendue compte qu'elle
diminuait d'elle-même pour devenir
réalisatrice
j'ai donc affronter ma peur d'être
visible donc de manière totalement
inconsciente potentiellement en danger
je pense qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
vivre ensemble si on se mettait permet
pas d'être authentique et d'être soi je
pense que pour être authentique il faut
accepter toutes les parties de soi même
les plus honteuses
alors quand je suis venu reset rice j'ai
pris par ma main ma vulnérabilité pour
me mettre en avant
surtout quand j'ai eu besoin de diriger
toute une équipe parfois 30 ou 40
personnes pour ça j'ai utilisé la règle
des 4 p vous la connaissez
j'avance en faisant le plus petit pas
possible le premier pas c'est plus
difficile parce que c'est le premier
donc du coup je place un objectif facile
qui va me demander peu d'efforts
pense que tout a un sens dans la vie
c'est ce que je me suis rendu compte au
fur et à mesure des mes expériences avec
le recul en fait j'avais j'avais observé
le monde sans vraiment y participer
pendant des années mais c'est ce chemin
qui m'a amené à faire ce que j'aime
vraiment c'est-à-dire m'exprimer à
travers des films et puis c'est cet
enfant ce qui m'a donné la niaque de
faire face aux aléas de ce métier c'est
au fur et à mesure de la réalisation de
mes films que je me suis rendu compte
qu'ils avaient tous un point commun
je m'interroge sur notre place dans la
société je tente d'illustrer comment
trouver un sens à sa vie
comment être libre et responsable
comment sortir du conditionnement qu'il
vienne de soi ou de l'extérieur
donc en fait comment vivre en soi pour
pouvoir vivre ensemble mon premier film
murmure raconte l'histoire d'un
prisonnier enfermé entre quatre murs je
voulais raconter la liberté dans
l'enfermement l'enfermement dans la
liberté
comment on enferme on met à l'écart les
gens qui ne savent pas vivre ensemble et
la difficulté de la réinsertion dans
notre société
récemment j'ai rencontré des indiens
kogis de colombie appelé aussi peuples
racines j'ai découvert que chez eux
lorsqu'une personne commet un délit quel
qu'il soit il est envoyé chez le chaman
qui valurent éduqués et lui réapprendre
ce qui n'a pas été compris cette
personne sera alors réinsérer dans la
société
et ça sera un excellent éducateur pour
les plus jeunes en fait toute la
communauté tire des leçons des erreurs
de chacun
c'est une société qui inclut là où notre
société est exclu
parfois lorsque c'est nécessaire le
chaman va chercher dans l'histoire
transgénérationnel du délinquant pour le
soigner et moi ça faisait des années que
j'étais fasciné par les secrets de
famille qui se transmettent de
génération en génération par
l'inconscient et j'en ai fait le sujet
de mon second film ces liens invisibles
sur la psychogénéalogie ce film raconte
l'histoire de trois personnes bloquées
dans leur vie à cause de leur douleur
ancestrale honteuse et cacher je voulais
montrer comment le vivent ensemble va
parfois au delà de ce qu'on imagine dans
les liens invisibles qui nous unissent à
nos ancêtres pour mon troisième film
j'ai eu envie d'aller au coeur du coeur
alors cette fois ci c'est une
coréalisation avec leslie coutterand le
film s'appelle ali love her for iam
ça veut dire j'aime donc je suis en
français est il actuellement en cours de
tournage
ça faisait des années qu'on sente et
impuissance passe à ce qui se passe dans
le monde face aux problèmes de société
aux problèmes écologiques aux violences
qu'on s'inflige les uns envers les
autres et aux violences dont s'inflige à
nous mêmes aussi et donc on est parti
faire une quête initiatique autour du
monde pour voir comment on pourrait
ramener plus d'amour dans nos vies parce
que on pense que l'amour universel et la
réponse à tous les problèmes de la
société
on s'est demandé et si on inversait le
ratio entre l'énergie que l'humain
consacre chaque jour à la destruction la
peur le jugement et l'énergie qu'on
consacre tout chaque jour à la
bienveillance l'altruisme et la
coopération
quelle société se déciderait c'est en
réfléchissant à cette conférence que je
me suis rendu compte que mes films
suivent et chronologiquement ma façon
d'aborder monde
mon premier film raconte l'histoire d'un
homme seul dans un environnement hostile
mon deuxième film s'élargit à la sphère
sociale en s'intéressant à des familles
et mon troisième film s'ouvre sur des
êtres vivants et sur la planète entière
et c'est un film plein d'espoir alors
pour expérimenter un vivre ensemble
bienheureux j'ai donc dans un premier
temps apprivoisé ma peur d'être visible
je me suis dit cette peur d'exister elle
est en moi mais je ne suis pas cette
peur devenir réalisatrice a donné un
sens à ma vie et avoir un sens à ma vie
m'a aidé à m'ouvrir aux autres
bon tout ça c'est work in progress à
l'inversé est vrai aussi c'est à dire
que quand je m'ouvre aux autres je me
suis rendu compte que je me sentais
mieux
en fait c'est un cercle vertueux j'ai
souvent entendu des personnes ne
racontaient que c'est leur rencontre
avec un grand sage un grand m il aura
changé leur vie ben moi j'ai pas de m
depuis que je suis petit je me dis que
chaque être vivant que je rencontre peut
me donner le son est peut être un maître
pour moi alors ce qui a en partie changé
ma vie c'est ma rencontre avec un chien
pendant des années je marchais dans la
rue
en regardant le sol un casque vissé sur
les oreilles la musique me coupant du
monde
vous savez comme ces enfants qui pensent
que si il ne vous voit pas vous ne les
voyez pas non plus à chaque fois je
lever les yeux je voyais des regards
austin est fermé et bien avec ce chien
j'ai fait l'expérience de gens qui
traversent la rue pour venir me voir et
dans les transports
on me dit au revoir et bonne journée ce
chien m'a fait réintégrer la face est
accueillante de la vie et de l'humain
sur une base quotidienne
il ne se passe plus un jour sans que je
rencontre des personnes souriante et
avenante
cette douceur c'est diffusé petit à
petit dans mes veines jusqu à en changer
ma croyance initial ma timidité
s'envolent chaque jour un peu plus et
plus jamais je ne marche dans la rue
en regardant le sol parce que je me
tiens disponible pour un sourire vous
savez que sourire libère des endorphines
qu'est la molécule du bonheur quand
quelqu'un vient vers moi en souriant là
ça me donne envie de donner de faire un
acte bienveillant à mon tour et c'est
toute une chaîne qui se construit j'ai
compris que le regard des autres qu'ils
soient hostiles ou bienveillant ça ne me
définis pas il ya des enfants partout
dans le monde qui comme moi ont démarré
leur vie sur un faux départ mais une
fois adulte on est l'unique responsable
de sa vie la vie n'est ni rose noire
elle et ce sur quoi je porte mon
attention
ce qui m'a permis aussi de me sentir
vivante c'est d'agir d'agir pour moi
pour les autres pour le monde
les jours où je me sens pas bien avec
moi même eh bien je fais l'effort de
m'ouvrir aux autres et d'agir avec
bienveillance et ça change le vivre
ensemble et donc la manière dont moi je
vis avec moi même
chaque jour je m'engage à me connecter à
l'amour parce que ça s'entretient cette
chose là je ne fais plus d'achats rien
que pour moi j'essaye de voir quel en
sera l'impact dans la communauté du
monde c'est à dire les hommes les
animaux les plantes l'environnement
alors bien sûr c'est loin d'être évident
dans notre société
donc pour ça j'avance en faisant le plus
petit pas possible je fais ce que je
peux mais je tente et les jours où
j'arrive à la fois agir pour le bien
commun et pour mon propre bien-être et
bien c'est là que je me sens dans la
plénitude et que je me sens sereine
des scientifiques expliquent que
l'individualisme évolué dans les
sociétés d'abondance et sécurisante
lorsqu'il ya des difficultés quelles
qu'elles soient les êtres apprennent à
se rassembler et s'entraident
j'ai pu constater ça dans des peuples
avec qui j'ai vécu qui vivent dans la
pauvreté ou dans un milieu hostile mais
qui pourtant sont heureux parce que leur
vivre ensemble est basé sur l'altruisme
et la coopération
les peuples racines se déplace en ce
moment pour venir parler aux petits
frères occidentaux parce que il y a
urgence
nous ne devons pas attendre de vivre des
événements de plus en plus difficile
pour apprendre à nous relier avec
bienveillance
est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé à ce qui
se passerait dans le monde si la té ce
soir chacun d'entre nous on se couchait
on se demande en aide apporter de
l'amour à quelqu'un aujourd'hui 2 qui
elle reçu de l'amour aujourd'hui et si
cette personne sané de personnes
aujourd'hui au moins s de moi même comme
vous le savez l'un des poisons de ce
monde c'est l'ignorance alors quand on
aura fini le film my love for high
sommes nous allons faire une version
pour enfants qui sera diffusé dans les
écoles avec des ateliers encadrés par
des professionnels
parce que l'amour c'est inné mais
surtout ça s'apprend se plaindre demande
moins d'énergie
4dans l'ouverture alors l'amour c'est
une décision quotidienne j'imagine le
même type d'école que j'ai connu avec
des enfants de toutes origines
mais il serait éduquer dès la petite
enfance aux valeurs de tolérance de
solidarité d'amour de soi au même titre
que les maths et ben je pense que ça
serait une source de richesse incroyable
pour le monde de demain c'est parce
qu'on se croit séparés les uns des
autres
convient dans le jugement la peur la
compétition mais l'amour c'est leur
appel à l'unité
aujourd'hui on vit sur le mode je pense
donc je suis de descartes avec leslie
nous avons proposé ilove therefore iam
j'aime donc je suis les indiens cow
guilleux proposes tu es donc je suis
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]